ouais plutôt non pas dans la neige pas
dans la neige plus tôt ouais ouais je
sais faire ouais c'est un truc
qui est très peu utile c'est parti pour
une vidéo assez original que personne
n'a jamais fait sur youtube au en fait
même moi j'ai déjà fait une
alors ça fait pas mal de temps que
régulièrement vous m'envoyer des photos
de personnes qui me ressemble et ça que
c'est souvent assez rigolo voire
cocasses
ce serait dommage de s'en priver donc
les gars michael cera et jesse eisenberg
ouais c'est vrai on se ressemble un peu
on est tout le temps on a un peu les
mêmes 1,3 trois acteurs bas comparé ont
un peu nos filmographie pourvoir à bas
tous nos cours 60 plus du tout tient
alors là c'est assez troublant c'est la
première fois qu'on me dit que je
ressemble à une grand mère qui prend le
métro et qui visiblement écoute du gros
son côté madame on vous salue si vous
n'êtes pas morte il ya un souci à moi
sportif qui aurait bien souvent c'est
n'annonce pas ronaldo n'aura zidane
c'est florian maurice qui s'en rappelle
c'est un joueur de l'équipe de lyon ii
de la renaissance
par contre ça choque que moi ce sourire
le mec on dirait il est trop contente de
faire du foot quoi
[Applaudissements]
florian maurice vous êtes viré du club
de foot
votre femme demande le divorce vous êtes
mort évidemment benjamin pavard ça fait
plaisir le mec il totalement style et
ouais on a le même problème lui et moi
très souvent on nous compare
physiquement à jeff tuche je laisse
benjamins à répondre jeff tuche comment
vous réagissez à surnom écoutez c'est
bien marrant au début mais au bout d'un
moment
voilà c'est ok une question
ouais john smith de mickey magazine que
pensez vous de votre ressemblance avec
norman fait des vidéos
c'est une très très bonne personne et
j'ai beaucoup aussi d'admiration pour
lui c'est un battant c'est un regard et
c'est un vrai leader
florian maurice nos lecteurs se
demandent quel est votre ressenti par
rapport à votre ressemblance avec norman
fait des vidéos
j'adore le foot a donc ce mec est censé
me ressembler le style le plus merdique
de la voie lactée
je rigole merci pour la photo ça fait
plaisir en voyant une autre photo pour
voir
le mec d'une photo à l'autre il est
devenu ultra léger quoi alors c'est vrai
que mon visage ressemble beaucoup à cet
acteur porno même si c'est pas un droit
que d'un trait ressemblance est la plus
frappante mais gabon
alors je crois que je m'avance pas trop
si je dis que ce sosie de moi féminin
est décédé cette personne est totalement
flippante 1 c'est la dame blanche
je me demande juste à quoi ressemble sa
vie quoi les enfants mamans après pas
haine qui dit pourquoi ils font toujours
ça et vous savez quoi oui qu'on monte
il ya d'autres sosies de moi de l'époque
apparemment il est le mari de la meuf
il ya son amant et le fils c'est la
famille addams parfait par le flic de
darcos c'est d'ailleurs grâce à lui que
j'ai commencé à faire ma petite
moustache et ça ça n'a pas marché
moi ça faisait plutôt cabrel ok donc nos
yann c'est vraiment mon sosie turquie et
en blesse ouais il ya une petite
ressemblance est à temps peut jouer un
petit peu a donc pour trouver sosie de
moi ta ta ta paix blonds bouclés vomir
yes d'accord dont sophie turner sort
avec ce mec
ouais ça me regarde pas je suis pas qui
est ce mec mais j'ai un peu le sentiment
qu'il est dans un mouvement un peu de
comment dire alors je sais pas qui est
la personne qui m'a envoyé ça mais tu es
peut-être daltonien c'est vrai que je
ressens la semec c'est normal puisque
c'est mon père quand il était jeune ok
donc ça c'est totalement mon sosie
sauf qu'il est beau bah c'est moi en
bout écoutez mon cousin bruce 53 ans
ok j'ai pas du tout et voir la photo ah
merde je les ai vus c'est c'est bien moi
ouais c'est vrai que je ressemble pas
mal à lui puisque c'est moi en fait il
ya ce mec qui fait partie d'un groupe de
musique
comment s'appelle ce groupe d'ailleurs
le groupe s'appelle les blancs moyens au
groupe de zouk n'ont cessé palais les
grands doit relancer les blancs moyens
alors ce mec qui est totalement issus du
moyen-âge et totalement la fusion entre
moi et eddy de brito par l'ust une
fusion entre mois maxime muscat nac feu
mais métis et roux web en fait il me
ressemble pas du tout ah oui lui
ressemble pas mal
il s'agit de jean teulé qui est un
romancier et auteur de bande dessinée
donc apparemment construit
ressemblera sa psg et j'ai hâte alors là
non je ne suis pas d'accord le mec à 0
poils sur le torse alors que moi moi moi
si en fait pour le petit julien qui nous
envoie un sosie de moi suisse
en écho alors simple dit souvent c'est
l'acteur du film simple alors lui par
contre c'est ouf c'est juste mon profil
c'est exactement ma tête quoi ryan
gosling serait que ça abusé là la
ressemblance et ouais c'est mon tweet
c'est mon truc j'ai beau avoir eu
différents looks dans ma vie les gens me
verront toujours de la même manière
c'est à dire un long tout maigre avec
une grosse touffe sur la tête voilà un
truc qui a bien souvent tahiti bob même
si avec le temps je ressens quand même
de plus en plus haut à flanders a les
dernières célébrités et pas des moindres
apparemment je ressemble à justin
timberlake alors pas ce justin celui là
celui qui avait aucun charisme
ouais cool mais voici maintenant une
peinture de mon ancêtre sirf et des
vidéos excusez moi est ce que par hasard
vous soyez pas mon ancêtre
est-ce quelque chose que physiquement on
se ressemble quand même beaucoup faut
que je me suis peut-être que ça se
trouve c'est grâce à vous que sur terre
donc oui normal je suis ton ancêtres
j'ai combattu désarmés j'ai fait tomber
les empires à la simple force des bras
pour que ma descendance c'est à dire toi
à cette vidéo sur les toilettes et la
raclette
ouais enfin j'ai quand même fait les
barbecues les vendeurs ouais je retourne
en 2018 un deferred tax gueule je suis
pas quitter west yeux merci à tous
d'avoir suivi cette vidéo mettait un
petit frère notre lot tarn à appliquer
sur la cloche pour recevoir les
notifications abonnés vois ma chaîne et
tout ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]